today's episode is brought to you by
liquid death
drink up
today's guest is a tall man and he's a
comedian as well
um
he was semi-recently affected by cancel
culture
over at saturday night live he is a
co-host of matt and shane's secret
podcast
with his partner
just friend matt mccusker today's guest
is comedian who i met last night mr
shane gillis
[Music]
just
[Applause]
how you feeling bro me yeah i feel
pretty good man i think i was just
trying to think earlier about how i'm
feeling i think sometimes for me it's
like i have to think about how i'm
feeling yeah
for sure it's like i think some people
can just are just feeling you know yeah
it's like when you're depressed
you gotta like figure it out because
when you're depressed you don't like
know you're depressed you're just kind
of like
i'm tired yeah i don't feel like doing
anything yeah you got to take some time
yeah people like why are you at this
animal shelter and you're like i don't
know i just want to say goodbye to these
guys
i don't know what it is i just want to
say goodbye to all these cats yeah yeah
man
i just i don't even know him but i miss
him
um
yeah man thanks for thanks for letting
me get up last night it's cool oh yeah i
was happy about it that was a good crowd
in there they were i was a little i was
a little like i couldn't figure them out
at first it was a weird nashville
you know there's certain states where
like austin or nashville or like
richmond was like that where it's like
aren't you guys supposed to be like
hicks
and then they're like ultra liberal or
like not ultra liberal but they're like
no we're not hicks right we care yeah
and then they over you know i think are
we recording this on yeah okay all right
good okay um
i wasn't sure i you know i do think it's
funny to find like a real country
audience like i my audience isn't like a
real country audience
um do you feel what is your audience do
you
i was trying to gauge it from the stage
last year yeah you don't know a man you
really don't know a community you walk
into like it's like putting on his pants
yeah yeah yeah yeah
minutes in um office i don't know i
don't really have it's new the audience
thinks so it's mostly it's just podcast
guys right fans like that yeah for sure
yeah you had there was one girl there
who was like i felt like she was not
even looking at the stage she was kind
of looking the other like she was kind
of sitting to the side where was she at
over to the right yeah i remember her
and she for me and she hated me she
hated me she hated me start to finish
hated me
and i hated her for it oh everyone's
wanna look at him what the what are
you doing isn't that crazy why would you
do this
she like it was matt yes i think that's
i'm glad she was mad during your set oh
she was she was mad dream i said and
even ari uh because ari mantis was there
and he went up before kind of a bigger
lady right
she was more a little more reuben yeah
kind of like a
more of like a rodent painter and like a
road in can you bring up rodin
i think anyway
yes
but yeah that was i was like okay this
is these are shane's these are shane's
bad girls out here yeah you think i got
the yeah she almost had a goth
appearance pale
r-o-d-i-n brother
that's larry rodden
who's also apparently a good artist out
of somewhere yeah it looks good
yeah oh yeah there it is
i think he did some oh there we go
what's that blob to the right oh
that's
i recognize that lady
fuming dude i used to go and i was in uh
school some type of school i would go to
the library and look at all of the
that was all my pornography is what i
would look at it was that kind of stuff
heavily bro i remember going in there
and i wouldn't get it going again well i
would get erect and then i would put my
erection into the book where
in the library right like up near the
shelves and close it as hard as i could
on my penis so you were like tributing
renaissance paintings i was yeah i mean
i was into like and i remember i'd go to
the certain section and be back there it
was dicey it's crazy i never really
thought about that i went through this
whole
deal to do that that's a lot it is a lot
that's a lot it's crazy did that it is
crazy you're sticking your book dick
into books and smash it not putting them
in i would open the book i like this
book
i'm not saying the book was asking for
it but i'm saying yes but i would do
that man i would just like uh
the book was willing to be able to
totally like seven years i was probably
13 maybe 12. this feels like a 7th grade
yeah endeavor just something yeah i
think it was just like
i think i just wanted to i don't know if
i wanted to meet a woman from the past
or if i
[Laughter]
was just that's how i could see
pornography
you wanted a woman from the past do you
think maybe i don't know i'm just trying
to think of why would i have done that
because dick it feels good to smash your
dick into things yeah that too and they
were naked ladies
yeah
porn back then was
impossible and if you could score some
porn in school yeah that's dude i would
look at like the science book yeah i'd
be like a skinless woman and i'd be like
nice yeah like you see your you
can see the inside of her you can see
the workings
dude so you just made even to the driver
oh bro give me this biology book oh a
little anatomy i remember two moons and
eclipse and i remember thinking it was
like breasts
oh yeah that's
yeah
you remember how hot like disgusting
teachers were to you oh man i remember
yeah who was your hot one who was your
hot tea we had a lady
that had giant tits but she must have
been she literally must have been 65 70
years old
wow but we were all like dude
what would you give to just titty
this lady oh none of us
were like seventh graders that's the
dark arts and that's when 9 11 happened
she was the lady who broke the news to
me about 9 11. no way giant tits lady
i couldn't i remember when i was young
if a teacher it was hot i couldn't even
hear them when they were talking to me i
think that's one of the reasons why i
did why i had trouble learning it
sometimes in certain classes because
it's like once they open i couldn't hear
anything yeah you were in the library
smashing your dick into books
you're not gonna learn anything you're
not gonna there's no chance you're
learning yeah that's true somebody
should have got a hold of you and
stopped you yeah that would have helped
i was at the library for so many hours i
think at some point i had this kid's
real bookworm yeah
this kid's literally studying hard he's
really i don't know how he's failing
he's literally worming these books over
here
oh and i and i would and i always had i
was oh we're allowed to drink these yeah
we can make these man that's sparkling
do you mind this is sparkling water flat
i don't know why i thought this was
this is water we're out drinking take
flag
it's water
liquid death water yeah
where's this stuff from flint i don't
know probably
yeah it's actually a good call
yeah how is this not liquid death the
sanctioned water of flint
they're having a tough time
oh wow
um
but dude nice to meet you last night
thanks for thanks for letting us get up
man yeah um we we kind of talked a
little bit briefly about oh we had a
question what is this one sean
hi theo
my name is joe and i'm a big fan
from little old england enjoying my bath
and i have a question for shane
um what is his opinion on age gap
relationships
um still seems to be okay
younger woman
and the older guy but not so much the
other way around so um look forward to
hearing your opinions okay bye
wow
that could be one of that's somebody's
school teacher whoa she's in the
bathroom it's a british asmr in a
bathtub yeah she's asking me about how
do i feel about older women yeah would
you bring me down here to make me come
dude no did you try to get me hard was
this a setup no i've never
huh no you invite me over here you put
on some asmr give me
rock hard give me some water
what are you doing
can you jerk off on this podcast
what's that what does she want i'm
looking for the question no we yeah how
do i feel about older ladies i've never
i've never seen that question i've never
seen that woman i'm glad she's staying
clean i don't know that lady um she's
attractive obviously i think she's
trying to look at the suds on her chest
a little i didn't notice that before
but no we didn't bring you down here to
get anything out of you man
[Laughter]
at all i mean just have some information
i guess
what have you just masturbated under the
mic and just left this is her question
no i agree i think yeah have you been a
yeah is that been a relationship are you
older yeah women i've i've been with
older women i like it
you do yeah
yeah
one less uh
do you guys want to talk to a lot of
people when they see me they want to
learn about my sexuality really i'm a
real yeah they want to ask me about it
because you have that politic you look
to me like a politician i feel like and
so everybody wants to know you know kind
of what bill clinton's really into so i
think you're the closest that i've ever
gotten closest to bill clinton today
yeah so far i mean hide in style and
like that
i think uh yeah older ladies yeah
sometimes when you're with
like a young hot girl you feel like
i it's this this is my job for this to
go well yeah but when you get an old
a geezer
that's right you just let her
whoa i've never done that oh what the
hell lady oh those you know what i mean
i guess i yeah i don't know what the
hell you doing down there lady i don't
know oh
yeah they really know how to pickle the
onions you know they do my lady pressed
my gooch oh wow fingering my taint
fire me up a little
oh my god
room's going crazy
yeah and that's
yeah that's our
uh
producer riley now he's never even
masturbated in his life which is true
riley the the never masturbated
give it a shot
no no no you can't he's like it's too
late now no he no it's not too i don't
think it's too late i don't know
hopefully he can i don't know he might
have autism i don't even know him that
well he's a great great guy and i'm glad
that he's here
sorry i didn't mean to bring that up it
just kind of fell in the conversation
that
and uh are you doing okay riley i am
there you go you just never masturbated
nope
he's re he's part of a religious group
and they don't do it how rel what type
of religion
uh christian
oh yeah i'm with you
i'm still firing him off he's with you
you're more of a hester
yeah
i was a catholic and they would talk to
you about coming oh okay oh i had some
priests asking me about you you grew up
catholic right do you uh or no we were
like sixth baptist i think oh okay
you ever get any guys talking to you
about come
we had a
professor i guess or i think it then it
was just a teacher you know yeah and he
would i remember he drew a picture
of a wiener
ejaculating
chalkboard and it was he like kind of
described like
he told us what the feelings would be
like we wouldn't be able to handle it
and stuff and then he
drew it like um
he drew the
the yeah the ejaculate just
coming out it was really insane was he
like
was he like making the noise with it
i remember he i do remember it was one
of those double chalk here comes a big
one
i remember he would put the marker on
the board and then walk
that's crazy it was pretty crazy man and
he wore the shortest shorts too he died
man willie i think
derek osner was his name or something
and i think his son might have died but
he died but
his son died too i'm pretty sure uh i
don't want to say that but i'm pretty
sure
and he had the biggest mustache like i
don't his words like i felt like his
words big mustache and he was talking
bro his mustache came over both lips so
it was like
the words couldn't even some of the
words you just had to guess what they
were people thought he was
some people thought he was black people
didn't know what was going on
we just couldn't understand what he was
talking about it was crazy you know it
was just different times back then
it was different times
but yeah i've never really had an
experience really with an older woman so
i i have not i haven't had that
experience it's nice
is it you just let them go
the dude i remember one time this one
girl was so hot i felt like i was afraid
to even go in the same room with her
yeah for sure so girls yeah i think with
regular like
you know legally aged women it can get a
little bit dicey but yeah i guess if you
have an older lady
you're kind of the little yeah the
little now you're the you're the meal
yeah feels nice to be a snack sometimes
you know what i'm talking about so you
don't beat off this is crazy we're just
skimming past it never once in your life
how old are you 23. all right you got
time
you're going to get one off what i think
i promise i promise you're going to go
oh dude i'll pat him on the back hard
enough
you know what i'm saying sorry brother i
don't want to say that kind of stuff in
front of i you know i'm not trying to
i'm trying not to jerk off and he
doesn't so it's
you know it's interesting
how many times do you mind if i ask you
about do you have wet dreams a lot
i don't
that's crazy what do you what happens
rally do you
and
yeah i mean but you're saving yourself
for relationships to talk about this or
no no we're fine
i'm gay about talking about guys coming
right
what uh
do you have a lot of sensations in your
body riley
not really no
i was kidding
you can't ask about sensations i'm sorry
man
can we even hear riley do we have him on
mike we do
uh do you have a lot of sensations in
your body riley
uh not really
are you serious man
you have no
feelings
i didn't know this bro
don't you get hurt have you had have you
felt pain
physically pain physical
what kind of physical pain like you ever
break a bone or anything no you ever get
a cut
i've gotten cuts what do you think what
that feels when you get caught
i don't know i put a put a band-aid on
but does anything come does anything
come out yeah
yeah all right but but you're okay
though riley you don't have like a that
you don't have a birth defect or
something i don't okay
that's what i was concerned with if you
don't have any oh it's like you're
behind us
no no i don't so you get erection right
okay and what do you do when you do do
you go outside do you put your hands in
like a
do you just calm down
i just ignore it dang wow that is power
bro it's pretty impressive that's power
do you like the carl malone of your own
dude bro i mean that isn't just train
baby
yeah wow i mean
that's wild man yeah and i i
i
yeah i don't want to see i just want you
to be i want you to be happy man
do you wish you never had
never had come
no yeah ejaculated there's never one
part of me that wants that yeah having
never i mean it'd be fun to experience
it again for the first time yeah that
would be nice
but no i'm proud i'm proud of almost
every one of them
almost across the board but
nice we did it
oh so you're in four eight there's been
a couple yeah
i don't have any problem with it
some of my boys are like you're trying
not to jerk off yeah i
feel bad when i do for some reason it
makes me feel i just feel disheartened
it just goes away right away wow like i
don't feel
my friends feel that way my friend matt
who i do my podcast with he's a big
like it's pigging out don't be gross
don't jerk off like that
and is that gives how do you say that
keebs keith mckeever that's john
mckeever that's a different difference
that's the sketch yeah that's the sketch
okay yeah yeah yeah um
wow well
but yeah that's i used to go into that
library and
and i liked it there and the lady this
is a reason we were able to get away
with it and i say we is just me
but because the librarian was the
largest woman in our town so
there were some stacks some books
actually couldn't even come down so it
was like that was great you could tell
if she was coming too yeah he's a
commotion yeah you would see a shadow
again you'd see a shadow you know what
i'm saying there would be some sort of a
like vibe
kid would be quiet you know something
would have
remember that was the best thing about
the library people were like yeah it was
fun shushing people yes and doing it
like as a dick yeah to yell
and anybody that was had you got to
shush them it was like uh
that quiet place movie or something yeah
or when it the best was when anybody got
in trouble and you got to go
you'd start screaming
my one friend used to like if you
with him at all he would scream like if
you like grabbed him somebody's like
shane get off for the last time like
you'd get you in trouble if you
up at all
it's very funny you can still do that as
an adult yeah you can you can be like
get the off dude i told you
i didn't touch him
yeah dude that was fun being a kid like
that was being a kid when somebody's
getting in trouble oh man there were so
many little levels to it
because you were free now yeah someone
else is in trouble so you can just be
like oh
the teacher's gotta be like everybody's
selling but you're charging her up yeah
yeah she's like yeah you are in trouble
dude everyone knows you're
dude the worst is when you got in
trouble it was like such a defeating
feeling you felt everybody's eyes were
on you i would like cry because i'd have
because i'd get in trouble i'd be like
yo my dad's gonna me up for this
now he would never like actually
i'd get like slapped yeah but i'd get in
trouble in school a lot
and every time i'd be like dude you guys
understand i'm gonna get up for
this yeah like stop giving me these
detentions yeah for like farting yeah
i'm gonna get hit yeah i'm gonna
literally get hit for this
and they had no problem with it they
were like yeah maybe you should stop for
uh yeah
our principal i remember we could still
get beaten at school oh really and i
remember getting spanked by the man bill
brady and i saw him at a funeral
recently and
he seemed like a nice guy i was actually
kind of glad he was the guy
at the time i didn't know who he was as
a as a kid i didn't you can't look in
his eyes and get an idea of him but as
an adult i was able to just look at his
eyes like oh man you're at the funeral
was it the come guys funeral uh
dick trolling no
no
no it's not that guy man thank god
funeral
yeah this guy yeah this was a oh this
fella that passed though he had we'd
been in a hot tub i've told this story
before this is like every one of your
stories is like yeah i remember this as
a kid now he has since passed
oh everybody dies man that i know
but
he we the first time anybody ever
ejaculated in our in our we were at a
party and someone did it in a hot tub
and none of us had ever seen it
we didn't know about it we didn't know
you could do it yeah
so this guy was erect under the water
and he was doing like a remember loch
ness monster the drawing yeah it was
very funny cool it was like the biggest
most important thing yes he kept doing
that a little bit just loch ness and his
wiener out the hot that's very funny it
was pretty cool man yeah especially at
that age we're done now he has since
passed
he is still alive this guy
but at one point he was i guess
pleasuring himself he leans up out of
the water
starts spraying out
this other kid thought something was
happening to him that was bad grabbed
his penis to stop it from happening no
and the other the bigger kid ended up
punching the kid but the kid that
grabbed him the safety key
the safety kid died
they say the kid who grabbed the penis
and got punched yeah he is overdosed
yeah he grabbed the he saw an
ejaculating penis he went because he
didn't know he thought he's got a bag
into this yes and then he got punched
too and died
hell was it's a terrible story
it's a tough life story um anyway man i
didn't mean to get off into all that
tangible no i'm glad you did i like it
oh
yeah man thanks for having me i like it
i like it man
i like hearing these stories i am man
that was an interesting one um
yeah thanks for having us over there man
i know we talked about what it was like
going on rogan and just like the
nervousness you know because you've been
in there i mean i haven't been in there
in a few years so
i didn't i forgot about that nervousness
when you go in right when you walk in
yeah yeah because the whole time like i
told you i was hanging out with him
during the week and it was like oh he's
the man oh yeah this is he is the man
and then you go in there it's like oh
i forgot that this is like
this is a big deal you know he's like if
sasquatch were a real person yeah you
know it really is it really is yeah
because i've been watching him and
listening to him for
years yeah you mean he's like holy
he is exactly who you think he is too
right he really is exactly that guy yes
he really is he's not a different guy
he's like a library with a bow and arrow
i feel like
you know he's like
he's just like oh i hear you the
information and the ability to like
share it and then
yeah he's fascinating yeah
and then you go in there so what i
haven't been to the new studio yeah
so you go in there and what's it like
you got you get tested for cove and all
that stuff wow and
there's this guy there's like it's just
nice everybody's nice everybody's
happy and
you go in and
it's yeah that's it how big is it like
this yeah it's like this it's like this
yeah and you go in and it's but then i
was up there and i was like oh i'm
bombing
well you sit on the stools was there a
back on the stool here sitting like a
with nice posture yeah and yeah i kind
of look like a i look like an
idiot so i don't want a
side angle of my slouched
slug body while i'm talking to this guy
well you have longer torso too so you
have
more slouch there's more of a
ability for you to slouch you're more
like you could have that kind of weeping
willow vibe yes
certainly so you have to really i have
less posture
you're funny you make me laugh
oh thanks everything you say it's funny
oh dude no i have less posture like my
body style yeah you have more posture
than me sure so i could imagine if i had
to manage an extra foot of
posture i would choke myself out it's
truly killing me anyway on stage
especially on stage i'm like this the
whole time no really bro i literally
especially because the crowd's down so
i'm always
if you see a side
shot of me doing stand up it looks
crazy
you can see i have a hump i'm i'm
developing a hump like it's bad
it's not great
i bought one of those things
that don't do this look at that one
right there there it is you've got it
looks like that that's like yeah it's
like something crap
it's all my failures
oh yeah
is there anything worse than googling
your own image
it's not great
it's not great stuff oh you look nice
though thanks man
handsome guys we're having fun
dude i wish i was taller
you guys are so you crystalia these tall
guys george wallace
george
the tall guys that can like hey here's
my arm you know
it's like you have that you're not
you're not like small though i'm regular
sized that's a nice
it's not yeah it doesn't do anything
would you rather be
short or regular no no you don't want to
be a short guy you're sad against
anybody short yeah you don't be a little
guy i don't think so there's some things
about being a little guy that i think
are nice
you think i don't know you get to scurry
that's true
yeah you're always you're going to live
you're going to live long oh yeah you
know that's big i'm big i'm dead soon
i'm going to be passed away you're going
to be telling a story you'd be like yeah
i had him on the podcast last week
since passed away but
you know yeah we were talking yeah
uh yeah we were man you know it's hard
to talk to people in person it's
it's grueling sometimes that's why you
need mint mobile
yep
after years of getting ripped off by big
wireless
and you know the hey art and fat cats at
t
lonnie t-mobile all of them
it's time
that you need mint mobile they have
premium wireless service starting at
just 15 bucks a month
a lot of us don't realize we caught up
in that washing machine of uh fancy fees
but not with mint
mint mobile secret sauce
is they're just the first company to
sell wireless service online only
they cut out retail stores no there's no
chop shop
that's right just 15 bucks a month use
your own phone with any mint mobile plan
keep your number and all your contacts
if you're not a hundred percent
satisfied
mint mobile
has you covered with their seven day
money back guarantee that's right to get
your new wireless plan for just 15 bucks
a month and get the plan shipped to your
door for free
go to mintmobile.com
t-h-e-o that's mint mobile.com t-h-e-o
cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a
month at mintmobile.com
theo you need help
i'm asking you and i'm telling you you
probably do i do
i do i just filled out a form yesterday
to get some more
mental health therapy you know it
i'll be there if you wonder what i'm
doing ever i'm probably
putting another
appointment with a therapist into my
ical that's what i'm usually doing
well better help
they offer it
they can assess your needs and match you
with a legit therapist licensed
legitimate bona fide
it's available to clients worldwide it's
not a crisis line it's not self-help
it's professional counseling done
securely
sometimes you live in a small area you
might live on a riverboat
you don't want to go get in a thing and
you know somebody shows up on a little p
rock on the side of the thing one night
and you got to talk with them for an
hour the other sailors see you
they point they laugh
don't be like that
betterhelp
facilitates great therapeutic matches
they can make it easy and free to change
counselors if you need you can do it
over facetime and you can do it over
zoom or on the phone visit
betterhelp.com
th t-h-e-o
that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
join the over a million people who have
taken charge of their mental health
in fact so many people have been using
better help they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
and this past weekend listeners get 10
off their first month
at betterhelp.com theo if you need some
help
check it out but anyway so i want to
know more sorry man
too much the rogan thing it was great
you go in and the nerves it was just me
and i and again he's done he does three
hours every day right so this is
literally nothing to him yeah it's just
like any conversation you'd have with
anybody but on the other side of the
table there's a dude that's like this is
it this is my thing i finally
get to get my snl story out to the whole
public yeah here we go
i started telling it and i was like in
my head you know when you're doing stand
up and you're bombing yeah you're just
thinking oh and you're while you're
telling your shitty jokes you're in your
head like what the am i doing yeah
that's how it felt like i was fully
talking about the worst you know when
you're thinking you have a whole
different conversation oh totally while
you're going well what's going on
terrible how do i look what's going the
the least i can do is look decent if i'm
not going to say no good i looked
foolish should have worn a hat no you
looked fine man and then i'm updated
you did well did he start off did you
feel uncomf because sometimes i didn't
feel like an idea wasn't it yeah it was
just me it was my idea of how things
would go
he didn't he didn't do anything wrong
you know he's just talking right but he
didn't know the other guy across the
table was like
cause i looked like i wasn't crazy did
you have a cheat sheet
no i looked like i was like having a
good time but in my head i was like oh
no
so he had no idea he had no i then we
get done i'm like i blew it didn't
i he's like what are you talking about
dude
yeah
i think i bet everybody says that to him
that's not like
probably a sociopath or something yeah
you know
yeah for sure especially like especially
oh yeah going in is a comic that's under
him you know i mean like i'm a newer
comic i'm not going to say anything to
him that he's going to be like oh wow i
never thought of it like that you know
what i mean there's nothing i can tell
him about comedy right which is all i
that's the only thing we could talk
about right you know
yeah man there's nerves of like and then
something back let's set it back up get
one back oh you'll go back hopefully
yeah he will yeah next time i'm coming
in yeah
i'm like listen
you better never make me feel insecure
again dude even though it had nothing to
do with you
i'm different
yeah yeah maybe tell them next time that
you felt nervous i think i did that one
time i think i maybe told him that i
said it i said it ten times yeah the
whole show yeah good then that's
real yeah i mean it was it was at least
real
oh yeah yeah yeah man that story was
fascinating the snl story i was and then
last night you said that you and lauren
still keep in touch a little bit oh yeah
yeah that's great yeah i'll text you
sometime yeah we chat a little bro i got
fired from bj's pizza dude when i was a
kid for
we're doing like this under the
dishwater contest kind of me and this
other guy
we got laid off but
uh what was the contest just be under
there as much as you can oh you get
physically you get in the dishwasher
yeah yeah you got to stay yeah that's a
firework
bro it was like the big it was like the
final one and i got i got i got
uh laid off after that but um
but i never talked to that guy again
wayne that hired me there no i don't
talk to those people i got fired from
several jobs several jobs and i just
never
i'm done yeah we're done there was one i
was i worked at a
nursery like a it was like for plants oh
yeah not for kids like plants yeah and
one of the i worked in the patio
department so i was like putting
together like they just put me in a
warehouse and they like put together
this furniture i would literally build
one bench and just lay on it
the rest of the day and they came back
they're like you haven't made one thing
i was just laying on a bench like you
know you're fired i was like yeah
it i'll head out
i would every day i would build one
bench and lay on it it was great
one gilla say stop
man um but so then what but you and
lauren still keep in touch though a
little bit yeah yeah yeah for sure did
he feel bad do you feel like i i believe
he did but you never know yeah you know
yeah you never know you never know he
could have been the one that was like
get rid of him
you know
but from his what i've heard is no
did you feel like whenever like you like
that you were going through that there
was nobody standing up for you or did
you feel like do you have any thoughts
like that sometimes you feel like that
yeah i feel like that most of my life
yeah the show is about that
but do you ever but did you feel like i
mean like i just wonder what some of
that was like like was there
there's yeah there's there's one thing
it's very surreal it's very surreal yeah
even your story listening to your story
about going in there yeah sitting in
there
i'm like in the story oh my god yeah
when you're in the waiting room like
because when you go audition you're like
i also never thought i'd get it i was
literally i was going in there like
probably not gonna get this yeah i knew
what i had done in the past
right you know
i knew my crimes i couldn't believe i
was in this building
and then uh
yeah you walk in you see that stage
you're like holy this is awesome
because i wasn't nervous until i saw
that
oh cause it's the real stage from yeah
you do it on the you audition on the
main stage oh wow it was crazy but uh
damn yeah it was cool it was cool it was
really cool but then when you get
cancelled nationally it's a very
also it's a lot smaller than you'd think
it is it's very small
that stage
wow i always thought it was huge yeah
murphy had been on there yeah
um sorry to bring that up but yeah but
he was on there so were you i was also
on there you were on there did you ever
feel like you were a patsy like it was a
setup did you ever think about that no i
don't think so unless it had something
to do with epstein
epstein was like that weak my story
overshadowed epstein ah
you never know bro there's a so much
power out there they could easily say
hey let's bring in a gentleman a good
gentleman and smear him
but did that ever cross your minor now
no no just from the way everybody talked
leading up to it
before the cancer like they weren't they
knew i wasn't like a conservative guy by
their standards yes i am of course but
they weren't like oh let's get this guy
because he likes trump it's like no i
literally auditioned with a joke about
trump dying right being funny
right
so
go looking back do you feel like there
was anything you could have done
different or it was just this was the
way that this was gonna work out no
matter what uh
no i mean i definitely wouldn't have
changed
what we did my our podcast
you know yeah that's yeah that's how i
got to new york right so
yeah it's interesting it's like
yeah that was just the way there was no
other way it probably could have gone no
was there a chance it would be less
funny if i was like pandering to try to
be a
improv snl guy
you know yeah that's a tough that's a
hard gig to be that guy
to be like oh i'm so silly yeah it's a
weird you know
look at me yeah i can't do that yeah
one leslie jones i like watching on
there because at least she has her own
charisma oh for sure there's definitely
people on there i'm talking about the
people trying to get on there oh yeah
like the improv world and the alt comedy
world that kind of like
i don't know it's not me drop these
raisins in the car yeah yeah just going
on stage and being meta every time about
comedy you know i mean when they do
stand up where they're like isn't
stand-up comedy stupid it's like
yeah yeah i like it but sure
whatever no it's interesting and i i
hope i'm not bringing up any bad
feelings i'm not trying to no i don't
care okay cool yeah thanks for being
willing to talk about it man yeah i
don't care at all
yeah i don't have any
ex
experiences like that except for
experiences of learning that i felt like
hollywood a lot of the stuff in there
wasn't didn't fit me yeah that's the
only thing i've learned over the years
like going to auditions and like trying
to be like um oh i'm just a
good guy that could be there next door
if you need to yeah you know for years
driving over and doing that and walking
in and knowing in my gut the whole time
that it wasn't me that was the nice
thing was when i got
cancelled was no more auditions
i'm happy about that i hate
auditions dude they're so bad
when you gotta submit a self
tape of you reading lines
and then you just know they're floating
around somewhere like somebody's gonna
get a hold of one it's gonna be you
reading lines yes some and you know
there's some perv out there so you know
this
but i mean just freaking
yeah
some dude has got definitely
just gotta be let me just get cranking
off the auditions definitely
because i remember i sent one one time
it was a they had to do you had to do a
shirley temple
thing a song from shirley temple right
bring up a shirley temple shot please
you can bring up a temple
and uh
and i remember mailing that off to
somebody emailing that video to somebody
me singing on a good ship lollipop and i
was like someone's gonna
so oh you jerked i heard you saying
shirley you danced and i didn't dance
but i didn't think they sent you the
lines and i never knew what it was for
yeah yeah yeah yeah but somebody
somewhere has
a shirley temple has since passed how
did charlie temple die
that's a great question
woodside california the cause oh
smoker
lifelong really yeah
lifelong cereal smoker but avoided
displaying her habit in public
she didn't want to say a bad example but
she's smoking
she made it to 85. lollipop i know
that's a great example yeah you should
be like look it's not bad i made it
they should put her on a marvel box or
something look who made it to 85. it
made it to 85 smoking chain smoking
through all that asani beach and
peppermint
hollywood sexual assault
she must have gotten destroyed
dude
oh my god
can you one of my friends said yesterday
he wished he could go back in time so he
could beat his wife right and i thought
that was the most insane thing i'd ever
heard hey but can you get the things
that women went through in the past i
cannot even fathom all the missing women
in the 70s you could just drive up and
pick a woman up yeah and they have one
yeah you could just take her out to the
woods and beat her just cry
it's great there's nothing funny about
that this he's getting hard
he's gonna jerk off we're gonna jar one
out of him don't say that to that guy
he's gonna freaking spray beef jerky out
of his body at this point dude this is
gonna be crazy you were like not your
goal for like three days it's like whoa
i still got it imagine 23 years i can't
even imagine that shirley temple has got
you fired up a little oh i'll tickle the
back of that leg
and it'll be spraying orange julius yeah
dude um
but yeah man thanks so much for letting
me get up on your show it's a good
podcast
yeah
i was excited you honored me dude
i was hired and fired by saturday night
live and i got cancelled
yeah
and it doesn't feel good when you get
canceled it hurts your feelings it did
it makes you feel
small
was the scary part about like what does
what about the articles and then
suddenly your name is out there
that was crazy that's because i was
never anything right like i did like new
faces that year
and then all of a sudden it was like
you're getting i was that was what
me up was like the comments
now i now i read comments i always read
i've been stuck reading comments
i can't stop reading and it doesn't like
destroy me anymore i'm starting to get
but it comes and goes
like i'll be like all right it doesn't
bother me at all and then every once in
a while somebody will get a
dagger on me and i'm just like oh
uh
but i would read like articles and stuff
and i i would have like dreams i was
having like nightmares about like
articles and comments and all that
it was crazy damn yeah it's just so
crazy to see your name that it's like
it's so much bigger it feels so much
bigger than you you're like i'm just one
person with
and
yeah and it was all it was it was funny
sometimes like it was very funny
sometimes like because it was with my
friend matt so like
i'd be like oh you remember we said
that like i totally forgot about that
and then there'd be an article it's like
judd avental's gayer than isis so you're
like oh that's pretty funny but you
know i feel bad that shouldn't you know
sucks that he's got to see that yeah who
judd apatow yeah
true yeah i don't think he he didn't
care obviously right
which is nice and yeah yeah because i
was down he could have been like
that guy yeah he easily chimed in
you ever get canceled are you gonna get
cancelled do you think now we'll see how
this episode does yes
this is going all right yeah i feel like
do you feel like we said anything
cancelable no
that's a good thing about you is it's
like i can ask you yeah yeah no where
are we at on these we're good okay okay
good okay we're good so far we're good
we're getting close with the picking up
women and beating them to death although
that was more me than you i'll give you
that but i was here the beat of the
death part was me yeah you said you
could just go around and pick them up
and that you would you wished you had
lived back then so that you could drive
around and abduct women my friend said
that you said
i could have said it but
i just i've been watching these ted
bundy things at night and looking at
some of his artwork you know he did
really good artwork a question came in
right here do you want to play this
oh we did a lot of artwork isn't that
crazy isn't that weird about all these
killers this is what my fans look like
just so you know uh is this your opener
stephen
looks like
what's up phil what's up nick
huge fans this past weekend
i'm out here in beautiful
philadelphia cutting lawns and
uh hedging bushes uh today i got uh my
tan going my john lennon sunglasses
this guys so my question today
uh shane
is i know you came up in philadelphia
so i wanted to know you know i've been
having this uh problem i wanted to know
uh
how many beers does it take you to
get incoherently drunk it seems to me
every time i go out
i uh tell myself i'm gonna take it easy
but i overdo it um
so yeah my question when you're sucking
down those bls those bud lights
how long does it take you and how many
does it take you before you're uh not
able to talk
thanks guys gang gang buzz
gang bro good question that is a great
question it usually
last night i got pretty drunk on
bloodlines yeah i saw you had a couple i
had a couple yeah i came out to see you
when you laughed
you like me good luck come back i'm
gonna see you tomorrow morning
i'm a idiot dude i'm sorry i
this is awesome uh yeah we went to we
went to the santa's
karaoke it was great was that
place is great oh my god it's perfect do
you drink i gotta go uh you don't drink
now right now i got like 65 days oh
so i'm off i just i just about
did just buy this vape
that's good they're fine you're fine i
feel bad about it i'm sure later on in
the day you can you got to have
something you're not jerking off or
drinking
oh i'm jerking off i'm just trying not
to you know
and it is impossible don't do that don't
do that well if i had don't put that
pressure on yourself i know that's the
problem i put too much on myself
i know man what are you doing with uh to
answer the question probably around 20.
really if it to get like incoherent and
this is over the course of like
seven o'clock show we're out till 3 a.m
yeah
and it's bud lights yeah you know do you
that's no she'll be sexually active at a
certain number of beers no yeah me
neither no
after like four beers wow it's trouble
yeah it gets dicey and then it gets in
my head oh and then it's in my head i'm
like i'm not gonna be able to get hard
but i look stupid yeah huh yeah
that's when you need an old gal
that disgusting yeah yeah she's like
don't you worry don't even worry about
your penis
she's hebrew for some reason dude
she's a black israelite uh one night i
was with mark maguire is that who that
guy was no jim mcmahon
uh
the old chicago beer right and he had
this lady who was old kind of older than
him okay or sitting outside and he's
just literally he would drink a beer in
one sip bro
he would drink a beer in one sip didn't
he just get like cancer
oh right there the glasses that's the
one i spoke with yeah i thought it was
mark mcguire dude for like an hour right
awesome they're both awesome he answered
all the questions i had about about him
yeah so it was almost oh you're like it
wasn't like hitting all those home runs
he was probably like this guy doesn't
know what a touchdown is it was great
yeah this is out of his mind uh but he
said yeah he had this lady who liked to
eat his butt that was with him that was
older than him and that was kind of
crazy
you ever do stuff like that get your
buddy i don't really get into a lot of
stuff like that you don't want to
put that out there publicly oh no you
mean you don't do it i don't do i don't
really i mean no me neither i would be
it would take i'd have to be at like a
you i'd have to be like a retreat or
something sure
some type of vacation or like a
rehab facility
that'd be a decent place to get it
though if things are going bad
someone ends up eating your ass while
you're like
but here's the weird thing
one of my friends who you know who's a
big podcaster told me that he does it
and he lays on his back and gets it like
that oh it puts his legs up
what big pocket i
[Laughter]
you don't need guys like this that's a
predator oh it broke my heart man when
he said it and i think i was trying to
be supportive and we were having lunch
and
god it just broke my heart that he got
his ass he legs up held his legs again
it was just
it was a lot for me to just take on
it's a lot
and i feel bad saying this in front of
riley over there i know
just a lot but um
anyway man uh what were we talking about
i got hired and fired by saturday live
yeah it was uh it was a traumatic
experience
um but you i feel like do you feel like
there is any positives from it over time
sure have you started to notice any
positives i noticed i noticed positives
immediately did you really yeah for sure
like you go on stage and people are like
oh this is
you know this is who this is this is a
guy oh wow so you went i never had z i
had zero and then to like oh this guy's
good you know
or like not good but this is a
freak this is who he is this is the
thing yeah this is we get to see this
freak yeah yeah but then it's in your
head when it's happening
because like you see people like at any
show people talk to each other like
whisper at the table and then like are
you talking about me
who are you i'm like you know
you know what i did
you
yeah so you'd be up there you just
you're in your head constantly oh and
then sudden like you meet people that
are all you know comedians in new york
and i'm like oh this hates me
probably or they probably talk or
whatever
so it's just constant and nobody cares
no one else cares
it's just you right i wonder what most
people feel or think i guess you never
know
it's weird how
it's like yeah do people even really
care it's almost like a lot of cancer
stuff it's not even a real thing it's
just it's no one cares no one really
cared exactly what you said yeah no one
did
i never once was confronted by one
person that cared really it was always
just like well you should have been
fired you can't dude
whatever
it's kind of weird it's like this it's
like this invisible rule book this is
and we're trying like
like right now like with me trying to
sell anything or like work on anything
like a show or anything people are very
like well we like you but you know
we can't get in trouble right it's like
no one cares about nobody's like the
reason we're not picking you up is
because what you did was wrong they're
just like well we don't want to get in
trouble
it's so you know it's like a weird
there's this individual
yeah god that
do so do you does that deter your any of
like your thoughts for future stuff i
mean i see you creating awesome stuff
the tr the uh
the trump speed dating thing was
hilarious bro yeah and yeah i was so
bummed because i'm like damn you have
such a great look for like being like a
new like daryl hammond or there's nobody
on these shows that looks like
anybody that i grew up with it's like
this guy this kid this is the guy um
yeah there's definitely like especially
nowadays you can just make your own
thing right look at this right you know
uh
so it's not and also there's what like i
don't do i want to be on a
sitcom
someone no i don't
i'm good yeah some of those days are
it's interesting some of those days are
kind of overflowing yes
right yes
i would be on blackish or whatever right
i'll do it yeah but uh
no that would suck i'd say yes probably
but i wonder if it would it wouldn't
come
uh i don't know i think just don't work
i've worked in
a long time having to work even when
we're filming our own stuff is like
this is hard that's hard i just stand
for a day yeah crazy
it's hard to do that kind of stuff's
hard yeah you just got to go sit in your
trailer and it sounds like it's all
going to be nice and it's this thing i
think
aesthetically or ast
aesthetically it looks nice to people
like on instagram it looks like oh i'm
in my trailer we're doing craft services
but it's just a lot of like waiting yeah
a lot of waiting yeah
that's all it is it's not like it's not
like obviously we're not comparing it to
roofing right but it is it's not
cool it's not as fun as you think right
after like the first hour of being on
set on anything you're like
yeah what do i do now this done
this could be a long day
but yeah
yeah i think that happens a lot man
my experience has been yeah then it's
just you're in your trade you're in your
like trailer you don't have a trailer
and you're just standing somewhere
eating peanuts and eating eminem's
eating and you're miked up saying all
types of wild worst
talking on the sound guy who's
literally just listening
the guy who was like cross-eyed
kept talking on this dude
and then finally someone was like
i was like
dude i was just playing with you
how you know i was around
you know it's hard to figure what gift
you want to get somebody
somebody you you might know somebody at
your house could be your wife or husband
and it's like damn they're
they were born and it's coming up again
i got to help them out
you know well
the best new gift is paintyourlife.com
yup
get a professional hand painted portrait
created from any photo at a truly
affordable price
you can choose from different
world-class artists and work with them
until every detail is perfect you can
help go back and forth hey
you know danny needs an eyebrow melissa
needs less mustache
send any picture yourself children
family
a pet
or combine photos into one painting
makes the perfect birthday anniversary
or wedding gift try something different
yep that's right
at paintyourlife.com there's no risk
if you don't love the painting your
money is refunded guaranteed wow
and right now at a limited time offer
get 20 off your painting that's right 20
off and free shipping
to get this special offer text the word
weekend
to six four
dash zero zero zero
that's weekend to six four dash zero
zero zero
text weekend
64-0 paint your life
celebrate the moments that matter most
terms apply available at
paintyourlife.com terms again text
weekend to 64-000
to try a new gift something different
i'm sure
your partner pet or
even you would appreciate it i hate spam
brother i hate the meat and i hate the
emails that are
you get them
everybody's always emailing me about
something facebook ads or some
roller skates
sick of it my email there's nothing in
it anymore it's bs it's
it's just damn jargon
well
the zebra if you're anything like me the
zebra can help
the zebra
is the nation's leading insurance
comparison site man come on
for car and home insurance
they do the shopping for you you ain't
got to do the shopping bro you're a
regular person
in just five minutes you can compare
quotes from every major insurance
provider side by side for free
all from one independent marketplace the
zebra pairs people with the insurance
company that's right for them delivering
quotes with the coverage they need
and saving people an average of 922 on
home and car insurance
combined come on that's real money
shop car insurance without shopping
around
get all your options in one place visit
the zebra.com
t-h-e-o that's the zebra dot com slash
t-h-e-o and now back to the episode
that's it see we got a question that
came in right here from some young
gentleman right here oh nice what's
going on theo what's going on shane my
name is cody from houston texas and uh
my question for shane is uh
what advice would you give to an
aspiring young comedian who has no life
skills and delivers pizza for a living
please tell me
gang gang
you should give them the advice
well
you got to get canceled bro i think true
to start
yeah bro you do something you uh you
know do something a little edgy
do something deliver a pizza yeah that's
shaped like a uh
illegal symbol for the german people on
it yeah
deliver a pizza somebody did that they
did yes
yeah with pepperonis dude i saw them
really i saw it somebody got in trouble
oh damn please look up swastika pizza
please google that dude
yes man
and the irony is it's made out of pork
isn't it
so that's a double entendre right yes
that's bad news
um yeah
that is a bad news
pizza little caesars fires two workers
you know how it went oh i've talked
about it you know how it went they one
dude was like i can't wait for him to
pull this out of the oven and see that i
ruined it and the other guy who just
must have pulled it out not even
looked at it just thrown it in a box
shipped it
that the other guy's sitting there like
yo what'd you do with that pizza
he's like dude it's out it's all it's
tracking
the trash you watched it like oh
it's at their house dude yeah who are
they
what's that look at their names look at
their names oh goldstein
juice only dominoes what the
you're like is it b-u-r-g or
b-e-r-g which one is it
oh man that is a freaking insane
so yeah
opening that i'd be so happy if i got
home opened a pizza i'd be like holy
dude the little caesars are
wild now they're wilding out man
uh look there's the two workers
oh wait no that can't be the two workers
it has to be
they just put two random could be the
victims little caesars
fired up
are we now that we're talking about this
little caesar says we're deeply
disappointed by the actions
but bring up little caesar this guy
looks a little third reiki oh for sure
look at them mussolini the guy
definitely no it's
no these are the victims
oh these are the vic they were his wife
misty
i love you
i love that people are named like after
kind of like weather like kind of light
climate conditions
misty sunny dusty
so my husband stopped at little caesar's
name dropping for a quick bite
husband brings this someone truly
disappointed yeah
ah
these aren't funny jokes and shouldn't
be made
it's true they're kind of funny jokes i
mean it's you don't think it's a funny
joke but a squashing on a little caesars
pizza
it's obviously a funny joke dude it is
funny it's funny yes i agree
it's a fireball
right and this is the owner of little
caesars
holy dude he's got a roman haircut
yeah that is holy
that's the drawing that's why bring up
the drawing it is
i think that is him
wow
i just
i wonder so so look that's caesar's logo
history if you wanted to be hateful you
have to be creative if you want to but i
think yeah you got to do something
that's out of the box and that's going
to
uh
and then once you're and then you i
think you got a rap i think if you're
gonna go from having no
you need to have something to come back
oh that guy does work at domino's
that is
the guy we're talking about that is a
chance he does
toss a symbol on a piece right
but you don't do that well i would what
i would do now is do something do
something in the other direction you got
to do a different type of symbol you
know i think you need to do like a mason
if they have a symbol you could do a
star david and send it to the people
that got the nazi pizza and make it up
to him
you could do a um
i don't know what you could do it's kind
of kind of the only symbol that's like a
yeah like i remember when we were kids
on a school bus we drew swastikas on
some kid named scotty's t-shirt that's
funny and he
went into aftercare we didn't know the
symbol meant or anything of course we'd
seen it on like pamphlets or whatever
around town and
and then we drew it on his shirt
and then he had to wash the shirt right
and so but he had to keep wearing it and
so like it always had it on there a
little bit it was crazy man i drew a
swastika on my friend's forehead once he
fell asleep no and he cried
wow yeah that's that charles manson he
because he has one yeah
yeah so i think you got to do something
you got to wrap or do something i think
to you got to really
or come out of the closet via pizza you
got to do something that's going to get
you
that's going to get your name out there
so that's wild so you went from and then
suddenly people know your name yeah yeah
yeah
for sure
is it weird when you see snl people
around new york city yeah friends with
like michael che right yeah
did you ask any of them to put in a word
for you no
no i didn't ask no right
what are they gonna do
yeah and that's like a up thing
to ask to be like hey risk will you risk
something for me like i was just
while it happened i was like oh i'm
fired for sure and then it just got
drawn out like i knew i was yeah
because i think if they were mad about
that there's there's other stuff there's
a lot right like this is
you know
do you think um
do you think
that you would have fired you
no but under the rules today's rules
yeah you have to right those are the
rules but if you want to you know what i
mean that's what i've always tried to
say like i didn't i don't
argue me getting fired right those are
today's rules if you want to talk about
like
i would have to argue like we need to
change the rules right you know yeah if
that makes sense i don't know if i'm
explaining that correctly yeah i think
so like the rules are what's
i this might not be what's wrong the
rules
there should be adjustment in the rules
yeah
well it's so interesting when you take a
stand up from what's okay to be on stage
and then try to put it because you
weren't a sketch guy really are you one
no
no not really so you're in that space
suddenly
and
do you feel like you were a good fit for
the show
yeah i think i could have been yeah for
sure i think i could have done well yeah
i mean we made sketches and i did okay
in those yeah so i think i could have
and i think lauren saw that and he was
like i think he could be good you know
yeah
uh
or i could have been decent at weekend
update something like that yeah that
would have been cool that would have
been fun
but
it's not the
it's all right it's fine
i truly i never like thought i'd get snl
or like wanted it right so it wasn't
like oh my dreams are destroyed right it
was a surprise it was just like oh
nice i got something they're like no you
don't i was like all right
back to what i was doing yeah
do you um and what is this here's a
picture you on stage with some other
communities oh nice
that's uh yeah those are some snl people
dave chappelle
oh wow that's cool that was fun
did they uh do like a special thing for
you back at the cellar or something when
they got back was there kind of like a
was that weird no i wasn't i wasn't past
it the seller you weren't no so this got
you passed you think uh it certainly
helped i didn't get paid they weren't
like oh nice you got can in fact it
definitely kept them and they chilled on
me for like a year or two i just got
past this oh wow congrats yeah yeah
thanks was there anybody that reached
out to you kind of that you were
surprised by that was like trying to be
supportive
yeah for sure it was a lot
yeah wow every every
yeah a lot of people did norma mcdonald
was a cool one really yeah that was a
cool one i talked to him for like an
hour no on the phone yeah wow that's
crazy
yeah what does he say
he's another guy that's exactly who you
think he is you know yeah he was just
like yeah
i don't know i don't wanna i don't wanna
put out the private right stuff but yeah
he was he was awesome
all that stuff all that stuff was cool
there was cool stuff cool stuff happened
but it was again it was very surreal
like you'd i'd get off i'd be like holy
that's like
top five for me favorite comedians of
all time just got i was just walking
around my backyard talking to him
and then i come back inside to my shitty
apartment
with my roommates with my 35 year old
male roommates
and i sit back down and turn the news on
it's like piece of shane gillis was
fired what a terrible person he is
and i mean it was just very surreal so
it was kind of like
i didn't even have time to be like sad
it was just
very stressful and like kind of funny
when i was just with my friends right
you know
because they would just keep quoting and
they kept trying to get us in more
trouble by finding old quotes
and every once while they they would
miss and they wouldn't be offensive and
it would just be funny
and they would publish them like a lady
from the new york times was like the
worst he called
civil women who fought in the civil war
secretly
flat-chested
she like tweeted that
people were like this is pretty funny
stuff
[Laughter]
she was like it's not funny
yeah they knew it it made me hate the
i hate journalists dude
la times in new york times it's the
worst yeah it's like what are you doing
knock it off
yeah why why are you trying to
somebody up
i get it if you're doing it for like the
greater good if you're trying to like do
you feel like people are though that's
that i know that's the tough that's the
tough part it's it's tough it's like
yeah are we aiming to do all this stuff
because we really like 50 years from now
you want everybody to not have any
judgments on each other or look at each
other in any
because the sacrifice that in the
meantime is humor a lot of times yeah
and humor is a risk like i always
the thing that was always funniest to me
was
a telling a humor or being a doing a
humor when you
write when it's not supposed to be done
like the guys are little caesars yeah
taking chances dude
yeah taking a chance yeah the guy they
took they took a chance man they
somewhere he took a chance dude and they
are probably legends amongst their
friends they are probably
uh truthfully look never put a swastika
on a pizza right not advocating that
yeah they deserved to be fired yes
that's a good cancel yep there's a good
cancel there yeah because it's dicey
you're using product to push your own
agenda
but those dudes are probably funny yeah
there's no chance those dudes are not
funny
because they're not real nazis they're
not right they were real nazis they're
not putting swastikas on pizzas
right they're doing other works they
understand how wildly funny it is for
somebody to open a pizza box
holy
and here's the crazy they're willing to
risk their careers now
it's so funny i'm sorry the word careers
is awesome there's that little
word in there yeah but they're putting
it on the line that's true they're all
in that's a good point like yo i'm
risking my little caesar's job
this is going to be funny
it just blows up it's basically like
german roulette is what it is a little
bit
uh you're right man so then the weird
part is the weird part sorry to keep
cutting off but just
when they got home and seen that tweet
that lady that misty said or whatever
her name was it's like oh she's
pissed
yeah we're in trouble dude
i wonder if they tried like 16 dude i
wonder if they tried to blame it on the
delivery dude i bet they did
i'd be scrambling to blame it on
anybody they probably had to interrogate
them separate be like your boy snitched
we know
my boy would never snitch on the
swastika pizza dude it wasn't us
fight could you find out how old they
were
yeah get the culprits and a picture i'd
like to see these i want to see
i'm going to reserve some judgment until
i say what if they're black
it's just like oh these guys are the
best what if they're black and jewish
and it was what if they're the owners of
the place and it was just a a plan to
get the
get some eyes on little caesars
that happens all the time i think a lot
of us don't realize
the way that publicity is used a lot of
times yes
you know like i felt mine with the snl
thing a lot that did get them a ton of
publicity that was the first time people
were talking about them oh yeah for a
long you know
yeah i couldn't name a yeah i couldn't
really name a a sketch outside of that
pete davidson chad when that even has
been going on in the past
few years i'm not a fan though i'm not
like a big fan anyway no i'm a fan of
some of the people i know that are on it
that are really cool but
yeah you're a comedian it's not like
it's it's not designs snl is designed
for like
high schoolers
right it's probably yes that's great
that's what that's their target so like
that's why everybody's always like it
was great when i was in high school
now
you know
i guess the thing that's interesting i
guess but you see guys like spade and
you see guys like kneeling you see like
norm mcdonald guys like that that went
through it
and chris rock you look at you're like
man these guys
are still funny are still
and their level of humor and their
ability to be funny in the spot is so
much i feel like
better than the ability of a lot of
people i know or myself or anyone these
days it's just like
i don't know if humor was just different
than or if
i don't know they just seem so much
sharper yeah that's fair
but you're only seeing their sharpest
stuff that's a good point you know what
i mean you're not seeing them
i bet if you went to a comedy club in 95
well definitely not so rock rock would
be
maybe destroying
i don't know if i define these
characters but in 88
maybe it wouldn't have been
yeah i think i've looked into this and
actually talked about this question as
well
but they didn't
show the fellas
they admitted responsibility
immediately terminated damn
oh i loved making pizza man i used to
work at pizza yeah
it's a nice thing got it very nice yeah
it's just rewarding you get it it's a
circle it's easy yeah there's a couple
shapes you put on you do this you do
that boom yeah you give it to some dude
someone up with you
people would lace him with drugs and i
remember we'd send a dude out he was on
lsd we'd give him a drug and then he had
to go deliver him and find out what
happened oh it was crazy sometimes he
would find him just in his car somewhere
we had a
christian fellow that would go deliver
for a while and we would make orders to
like danny glover he didn't know any uh
danny glover he didn't know anything
this was in louisiana he didn't know
anyone entertaining this guy so we'd be
like danny glover we just he was oh you
would write the name yeah he'd deliver
on sunday i said so he'd write like
danny glover and he'd go drive 40 mile
middle of nowhere to deliver to glover
and he would wouldn't be danny glover
was in louisiana never was we would just
make it up and send this i see i see i
apologize i'll give you all the clues no
i should have definitely picked that up
bye it was on me yeah was it
um here's a question that came in right
here
sup theo sup shane i had one question
for shane today and it is
when is that special going to be
dropping if it is dropping that you
taped in austin i was there so i would
like to see that again just wondering if
it is going to drop
nice
uh i should it should be out it'll
probably just be on youtube uh
and it'll probably be like first week of
like september
around there wow soon yeah yeah did you
feel good about it i did
i think it'll be good that's cool we'll
see i don't know i now watching it i
hate it you know what i mean like
sitting down to have to watch it and try
to like they're like what joke do you
want to use here and it's like they all
suck i know i look like a idiot
up here
were you worried about what you would
wear on it no i wear the same
like every day yeah so it wasn't
that complicated but i did like spazz
and get a haircut like right
before
like right before it i got a bad
haircut
bad dude
i look
like a crazy guy
it's like
it was
it was so ridiculous it was just a
nervous panic i went to like a
i went to a dominican barber shop in
queens
the day before i filmed oh and got like
a tight
skin tight fade on the sides
see the worst part of this and then dude
he oiled my hair
he gave me a full dominican haircut it
looked crazy oh my god they put
oil in their hair it's just oily i just
realized you look like you ate off
hitler a little bit
sorry bro i just realized this
don't do that bro that's not
it sorry man you're handsomer than him i
think
there we go
[Music]
yeah get fired up
did you oh there's a pizza yeah i got a
slight
yeah hit
last night you said one of my i was
thinking about it all day
you were like we were talking about the
holocaust again for some reason
we were a little bit but we were talking
about oh cause we were talking about
hebrews nothing bad we i think we were
with the jewish man we were just
discussing yeah how uh
and then you made a joke i hope we can
edit this right
if it's bad if you feel bad that i'm
exposing a funny joke he made okay about
uh you like
it's like you'd think there'd be more
there's incest in the jewish community
yeah and you're like that i think you
were like yeah because of the holocaust
yeah they were all
in the same space
yeah that's what i thought i didn't it
was very funny and then you were like
hitler how far did hitler live from the
holocaust
yeah that's been me off all day
really it's so funny
thinking of him do you think hitler
commuted to do the holocaust i just like
went to work
i didn't know
like he checked into an office i was
like all right things are this is good
this is what i planned
yeah i did i think yeah i always oh
because i grew up in the area of a lot
of incest and so when you're around
incest you learn about other incest you
know you kind of you know water seeks
its own or whatever
but
so
ari manus who's my opener who's jewish
is always that's what we were chatting
about yeah he told me that a lot of
incest in the jewish communities because
or i always thought a lot of incest and
he said there's a lot of incest in
jewish community yeah he said it so i
always thought that
it was because yeah like the holocaust
people are stuck together you have sex
with whoever is local to you yes you
know which is the same reason that they
had incest in our community growing up
yeah or a lot of rural communities like
ireland
yeah people don't want to go that far to
have sex
bottom line
it's sad to say
but if somebody you know but i think the
holocaust was maybe in the ghettos
before
but the holocaust i think they separated
men and women right and that's what he
said and that shocked me
but
because i've read uh
i don't know why it's so funny i'm sorry
no it's just saying the holocaust is a
place is very funny
just being like
i'd be like does he did he go to aids
it's not a the holocaust is a thing
yeah it's not a place because what was
that book i read oh sir
i don't remember it was it was freaking
good though but but it was about the
holocaust did you stick your dick
you're just reading night by eli weissel
just like oh
oh man i gotta are we allowed to tell
these jokes
i think we're okay i'm saying it you're
not yeah and i don't think we're
nobody's saying anything bad we're with
jewish people we weren't we didn't say
anything bad and i i just that that's
something that i thought i didn't know
there's nothing wrong with not knowing
something true um
but
yeah and then i didn't know like i
didn't know i never seen like the charts
or anything like where did adolf hitler
live at like that i always thought maybe
he lived
like out front or something i guess i
guess i equate it to like slavery or
something you know not that it's the
same thing but i just equate it to like
a bad thing and then i think in my head
i'm thinking oh well the slave owner
probably lived on the edge of the i see
yes
in that case the comparison would be
like an ss guard
yeah
while the president
you know what i mean an ss guard would
be like a plantation owner right but the
president
he wasn't like
coming down to plantations and being
like
my plan's working right right you know
what i mean yeah i bet hitler definitely
went
that's crazy actually now you mentioned
it yes i bet he did go inspect
you're like nice
i can't believe it's worked that's crazy
this idea you know
it's crazy man
this is crazy when you put your mind to
something
just to see it here brick and mortar
how do you think hitler was pumped
he was like holy man that's
up do you think hillary was with his
boys like every once in a while i gotta
just take a step back and be like we did
it you know
that's hilarious it sounds like a louis
ck bid almost definitely
hitler hitler killing him killing
himself reminds me of a
hitler just when he killed himself he
killed himself in a bunker did he with
all his boys wow and the soviets were
like in berlin and they were like oh
they're about to get him he was he was
about to get caught and he was like
you're not gonna get me
and he killed himself
that's correct which is pretty funny
wow
andy just he just said i'm done yeah at
the end he was like well you're not even
gonna get me you guys can't get me oh
it's so it's such a move
yeah but in his defense yeah he was
definitely gonna get
he was gonna get in trouble yeah at that
point everyone was like oh
yeah yeah yeah you do dude what the
did you do hitler
the whole world isn't it crazy how
nobody knew kind of what was going on
that's the craziest thing to me yeah
yeah you can't keep anything a secret
now no you know you can't even keep a
couple you can't even keep
you know actually some people could keep
a secret they had like that elizabeth
smart girl was locked up for like six
what's that about months kidnapped
people they had those people for eight
years in cleveland in the basement
that's crazy
but i guess you just don't know what
your neighbors are doing
just being locked in a basement but it's
crazy years
there's some guy that locks you up what
did this guy ask us
oh he wanted to know when this special
my special one's coming up mark norman's
had a great success with this especially
on youtube yeah it's pretty cool yeah i
think that's that's a pretty reasonable
option yeah it's a yeah and if it
doesn't work it's on you
you know if i put it out and no one
likes it will you put it out in a full
segment or clips do you have any i'll
definitely put clips out yeah that's the
thing you got to put the whole thing out
and then you put clips and all that
which you know it sucks to have to play
the internet thing that game i'd much
rather have
like an hbo or a netflix make it
and that's it i don't have to do the
whole
because like right like schultz like
schultz talks about it i talked to sean
andrew schultz a lot about it because he
does it
you gotta if you're doing it on your own
like this is what he would say if you're
doing it on your own you have to be your
own marketer right which is hard it's
hard you know what i mean it's hard to
be that is it i don't like it i'm
uncomfortable trying to market myself
oh i guess that's interesting but i
think if you just put the put it out
there a lot of people will find it for
sure putting it out yourself i'm talking
about marketing it to be like hey here's
uh
crazy captions on the bottom of my uh
and you gotta do thumbnails and you
gotta have titles that are like white
guy slams indian right you know what i
mean yeah some of that and that stuff
sucks
i don't like i hate doing it and most
you'd be surprised how many people hate
doing it themselves but it's
the right thing to do
yeah it's interesting some of it's like
some of the but sometimes the material
can just stand on its own and you don't
need like the big but you sometimes you
do have you have to get some of it you
have to get the wording or something to
get people to see it yeah there's all
those tricks that otherwise if you were
handled by a network they would just
handle it they would just do it
themselves but if you're doing it
yourself unfortunately you do have to
play that type of game
it yeah that's a good point
i heard that uh
mark norman's was like the seventh most
watched special yeah um
if you liked
over like you over hbo showtime those
sorts of uh the ones yeah netflix
doesn't release theirs right they're not
sure they don't release their metrics
yeah but norman put on a youtube special
and it's number seven that's pretty
crazy it's pretty crazy that's really
crazy
so that's a lot of eyes man yeah
hopefully we'll see hopefully exciting
hopefully it does well if it doesn't you
know i'll just
kill myself
in your bunker bunker
like guys
for real we kind of did it anyway
and the the the the artist with his boys
like i mean i told you this was good
the articles were probably like racist
pizza
takes his own life who would have
thought that that guy's idea
adolf hitler's
we're talking 19
after world war one he's he's
wounded he's saying his
idea
would someday reach the whole way to a
little caesars in ohio
and just someone's day up
in 2021
but this is one thing i think that's
good butterfly flaps its wings type
scenario yeah
just a guy in austria gets denied from
art school
somebody's getting a up pizza in
the future
but this is the interesting it's just
crazy about the world like you could be
someone who could have the most negative
or positive influence
and
a hundred years later 150 years later
the best you're going to be is a joke on
a pizza you know true
it's like
um
also i think
it's also kind of cool to see the that's
where nazis are now it's like there's
not it's so like that's one thing i
didn't like about the charleston thing
whenever those guys came out with those
uh
tiki torches you know and they're like
these guys are all nazis it's like
if this is if if we're down to 60 people
yeah with tiki torches then we're that's
great yeah like that's great true that's
how i see it like at least you like it
wasn't like there was like 30 000 people
yeah meet up i think yeah if you look up
how many dudes are like actually in the
kkk yeah
probably 60.
no i think it's like seven thousand but
that's really it's still pretty good oh
damn that's like one high school
football stadium that's a good point
it's not that many guys yeah and if
we're down yeah it's like sometimes it's
like you gotta look at some things as
being pr i feel like as
you have to look at the actual progress
yeah it's like that's actual like
if you compare to some of the pictures
of like how many nazis they had 200 000
200 years ago 150 years ago yeah they
packed madison square garden
unbelievable they filled madison square
garden in like the 30s did they really
yeah wow the nazis were big dude the
nazis were doing good and then hitler
they took it a little far
yeah
oh whatever we don't need to look up
yeah how many clan members are three
thousand thousand nationwide it said
interesting that's a lot of that is a
lot actually i mean it is a small
amount for a country but three thousand
dudes are still like
hey yeah yeah this kind of rules
but i wonder if they're also just
including fraternity kids that do that
and that they'll be like oh these guys
are white supremacists i wonder i think
that's probably like estimated like 3
000 like dudes that are like no i put on
the hat
i'm nuts dude i'm i'm in
it i don't know what else to do that's
crazy
i wonder how many because the crazy
thing about that the crazy thing about
the white power sign is they took the
okay sign basically and made that said
oh that means white power well i think
wasn't it a joke when they did that
they i think the guys who said that that
was uh
to make everybody
follow through with it i think i could
be wrong can you look that up
i think there was like a 4chan thing or
one of those guys type things
and they were like it'll it'll just make
people look silly when they're like
actually that's a secret white
supremacist sign right when it's like no
it's it's a-okay or it's this game where
you punch your friend in the arm right
but the craziest part is if you then or
then you become a white supremacist
you're like yeah
but the crazy part is you look back
through time so many pictures of people
were like okay in the past everything's
okay like look at this white supremacy
jesus and then you every and you
have everybody doing it black
everybody's like oh look at this
guys are hitting threes in the nba
totally like oh remember
lebron
lebron's one of us
was in my clan
that's crazy man uh would you still
submit a packet for snl do you think no
me yeah no
would i submit one i didn't submit one
ever oh you didn't they asked i was
asked to by my agents and i was like i'm
not gonna submit a packet yeah writing
i'm not going to get a writing job there
i'm 33 yeah i'm not gonna go be a writer
yeah
uh so no
i wouldn't have that i'm too lazy
yeah i can't sit down and be a writer
and then have somebody else go tell the
jokes yeah that'd be tough to watch yeah
you ever write on anything like that
yeah it'd be so i can't imagine writing
a joke and then watching another guy get
laughs
oh and some people do that and they have
they're totally happy doing it yeah
yeah i have uh yeah i have some friends
that are writers it's got matt gold that
she's a great i mean john mckeever is
one of my guys yeah mckeever he's he
writes almost all those wow he's yeah
he has no problem being a writer
i'm just which is probably a good thing
it's probably a healthy thing to be like
no i don't care who who gets the
adoration
i'm like i should they should laugh at
me yeah if i wrote a joke and somebody
else told it i'd be like piece
of oh stole it
i gave it to him you know
you think about swastikas
yeah i think well even this wants to go
pizza guy it's like
i was trying to tell the guy you have to
do something you have to put someone on
a pizza and it's already been done
yeah so you got it yeah you just got to
think of something kind of creative i
think
um
yeah when do you think that you were
part of like you know the eight the
asian hate thing started do you feel
like getting it yeah you do pretty bad
luck do you feel like you started that
at all uh
no but i was actually yeah now you
mentioned it yes i was one of the first
i was definitely early in the asian hate
community because after that it kind of
that's when it kind of took off i feel
like that's when
yeah
but you it it wasn't obviously
i mean that's ridiculous
no that's fine
it was kind of yeah i mean it was media
attention about a slur right directed at
asian people so yes that definitely and
and and people are perfectly reasonable
to see a headline that says this guy
said this slur
and they're perfectly reasonable to be
like that guy
you know what i mean yeah because no and
i do the same thing i don't read
articles i see a headline i'll
be like oh they're guilty yeah
them or there's no context or who knows
how the does the washington post
report on a podcast from 2018 right and
see the accuracy they're using here or
are they just like this guy's getting
fired for being racist
clicks
clicks clicks it's crazy huh yeah they
don't get no one cares it's all done the
caring is done the the problem is though
is when they write those articles
after what i've said that doesn't count
when they write an article that says a
slur
like this guy used this slur then normal
people who obviously would have never
heard
matt and shane's secret podcast
are like holy
he said like they're just
in the new york times it's like here's
the word that that guy said that's bad
right that would have never reached
these people ever
you know what percentage did your
viewership go up after the article
it probably doubled
yeah since the the months after after
snl our
listenership probably quadrupled
yeah for sure because then people heard
about it and watched it so it's helped
the problem this is actually funny yeah
it's helped the podcast tremendously
wow yeah but it's not like
it's not like it's helping the podcast
in that like racists are showing up and
being like hell yeah brother no it's
like people that are like oh this it
sounds you know i was trying to figure
out who the pizza guys were
yeah it turns out if they were putting
out some more funny content i'd probably
i'd probably check in with them and see
what they were up to once you're in the
news people are going to look at you and
be like all right this sounds kind of
funny yeah where does this go from here
if it's bad you just close the window
yeah
um
and we're not condoning this guys we're
not condoning it
um
that's a scary thing now it's like you
don't it's like the people who are
judging they don't care if it's a joke
or not no
no they don't care at all
oh yeah you got that thing
tonight
yeah i was just thinking i was like
what's he got to lose oh tonight
yeah i was like yeah i'd be a little
cagey maybe i don't put this out until
that's done
but will we ever be able to put it i
think
do you think this podcast is too much or
not no this podcast is not too much i
know it's not okay i'm certain it's not
it's clearly joking okay very clearly
joking yeah i just want to make it clear
we are joking if you were putting up
like pictures of like
i don't know horrible things and being
like look at those losers
i'm glad that happened
that'd be bad yeah
yeah i wouldn't do anything like that
you don't seem like you would do that
you don't seem like a very
mean guy
do you ever freak out and get mean to
people
sometimes i get angry but my anger is
all always usually just inside of myself
it doesn't have anything to do with the
people outside of me yeah so sometimes i
react i interact with the world angrily
but it's just the way i interact with
everything are you ever do you get mean
to people you don't seem that you seem
like a very nice guy i think i'm pretty
nice guy i just
i think uh with work and stuff sometimes
i get kind of demanding i think yeah
someone's like around are you ever like
you can off dude get the out
of here
spit on anyone no
i never spit on anyone one general she
was asking about it but was she yeah she
was this little
pretty tall girl not that tall but
kind of normal heightened i guess
regular
yeah cool girl pretty cool she was
pretty cool i don't know i don't know
where that good
um i've been getting angry lately have
you yeah i keep waking up because the
girl the girl i've been seeing she
screams in the middle of the night
sometimes oh wow she's just all all the
time actually like every other night
she's like
three in the morning
and every time i'm like
if i'm waking up if you're waking up
scared you're gonna be mad you know what
i mean like every time i wake up like
what the
she's like
shut the up shut up
because i wake up
shut the up
shut up and then she wakes up to me just
every night screaming at her because
she's asleep when she's she's screaming
so she's coming out of this sleepwalking
to me like go to sleep shut the up
that's how every night she wakes up at
four in the morning to me like sitting
up in the bed like would you shut the
up
it's a real terrifying
terrifying relationship is she sleepwalk
sometimes so the other night i woke up
and she was standing in my room naked
in the room in the dark it was it was
dude it was scary i left the room i
slept on the couch
i was very scared and then i was afraid
i was afraid of my girlfriend i was on
the couch like she walks through that
door i'm this is terrifying dude
dude she got you right where she wants
you so scared
oh man oh my god you ever have sleep
paralysis that would that'd be something
like this is insane but i up
love it dude i've only had it once and
it was it was uh the worst possible one
it's crazy it's a demon standing at the
foot that's she reminds me of she's just
standing there wow nothing scarier than
like a naked person in the dark
yeah
but yeah i had sleep paralysis sleep
process is good man i like it i feel
like it's a sign of things to come it's
excitement i feel like it's
you know it's almost a demon oh really
well yeah it's mythology it's uh i saw
that guy that's the scariest part
no
let me tell you this this is
these images so i didn't know what sleep
paralysis was okay one night i was going
through a breakup so i was very stressed
out and i went to sleep in my parents
basement and i woke up and there was a
that exact figure standing at the foot
of my bed and what is it standing and
then it walked around the side of my bed
like reaching towards me and it's so
real yeah
like it was so real that i thought it
was a intruder oh i couldn't be like
this is a demon i was like oh
someone's in here
even though they looked ridiculous they
look like the slender man and they were
like walking around the side of my bed
reaching towards my face and then i woke
up right when they got there but i like
it was so real i tried to fight them
like i thought it was real and you
couldn't even when i woke up i was still
i got out of my bed and was hiding on
the side of my bed
and then tried to fight this
thing and obviously it was gone but then
several months later i was just looking
at wikipedia there's like lists of like
creepy wikipedia articles which is a fun
read yeah it's fun to pass a time and
then i saw sleeper houses so i clicked
it and the image was the image from my
dream
so i saw
something i saw in my dream on the
internet months later after after it's
crazy
oh see that makes me it's the one with
like the red eyes leaning keep going
down you'll find this you'll
never find it true that's
the one that makes me uh
seen this is
but it's just crazy yeah everybody sees
the same thing that's what's oh
they do very spooky yeah dude i saw
somebody drew what i saw in my dreams oh
that's insane
i feel like yeah i always feel like oh
something's
go to images on google you'll find them
sleep right now get me i
i feel like something's coming to get me
you know
it's right here and i don't know yeah
but i never see the thing i gotta look
at all the things
you don't want to see the thing
you'll find him yeah it's that guy with
bottom right or now he's bottom left he
was standing at the foot of my bed
wrong one but that's all right swinging
a mist
go scroll down a little
right there that guy
nope
are you with me no he's not
this is what this is how it is
you were on it i was like that's the one
this is how it is and this is how that
works that guy this is what i get going
that's what i saw dude
this guy right here yes
at the foot of my bed except my guy had
like a more white face
okay
so almost like a black guy in white face
kind of
wow
even the scariest that's the scariest oh
that's you know what world are we in
where black guy is doing white face
lester holt really but lester older i
feel like lester is secretly a white guy
you think oh
i don't know much about lester holt pull
up a picture of last year please
this will be
12 minutes
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh yeah
you telling me that's not a white guy in
blackface or in tanner
i think uh
yeah that's
this is a tough one
i i i
lester i mean stevie how'd he look when
he was younger
oh that's a great oh there he is right
there that black if that's him in the
black and white
yeah
really that's him wow oh dude
even he like transitioned
even that seems
like a white guy in like a wig kind of
yeah
this to be honest this is you you are
getting borderline this type of thing is
a little dangerous it is speculating on
black guy's race oh damn okay
look as i'll tell you where the line is
okay we're getting close okay sorry
then back me out i've just been there's
been a lot of discussions here's sean uh
king
sean king uh-uh i've heard of him
he was like a activist oh and he was
wide out he's like pretty white oh it's
crazy now that's that's i think you can
take that shot publicly oh here you go
but here it's going to be in the future
everybody's going to be beige and it's
going to be ridiculous we were all even
arguing about race stuff
yeah for sure like we're it's basically
it's funny for white people to say that
though to like be
the purveyors of racism for the longest
time and then towards the end be like
what are we even fighting about
it's like you don't get to decide that
it's very funny it's like when a girl
fights you
and then she's just like
she starts crying like what are you
crying about you with me yeah
it's an easy out it's good for the
honkies trying to hit the eject button
like damn it what are we doing talking
about
maybe i maybe i have such a white
perspective sometimes no i don't think
that's what you're doing i think it's a
reasonable thing it's not like that's
the thing there's it's it's easy to
compare like racism and all that stuff
to like
well if you punched me i'd be mad about
it but it's like are we talking about
our grandparents or our ancestors right
like i that's where it gets murky
because it's like well i didn't do that
yeah
but like it's all you know it's
confusing eric griffin has a great joke
he's like it's like when you walk in an
elevator and somebody farted in there
but you didn't do it you know and
somebody looks at you like you did
you're like
i didn't fart but i didn't yeah
yeah but the smell is still there but
the red but the but the effects of it
are still around certainly and eric's a
bit he was he fat was it was he fat he
looks like he's skinny now he used to be
thicker than uh
he used to definitely
he would have been a hottie at spring
break trust me as a big guy myself i
know what it's like the fart the far
blaming
it's in there it happens
if you're a big guy if somebody farted
in this room i'd you guys would be like
really you're being a fat guy on a plane
you're getting hit with the looks oh
yeah there's somebody their pants
everyone's looking at you
yeah
yeah that could be true yeah yeah it
could be true man i think it's also it's
grandparents a lot too one more question
here we got
yo theo yo shane
got my other drip what's going on gang
baby bang gang salt life the whole nine
shane my question is tell the story
about how you made dave chappelle run i
think you've only told it on like dad
meat and only took like two minutes can
i get a full
in-depth story about how you and i think
it was okani's made show made chappelle
run
that'd be great okay it's kind of a brag
yeah yeah i made chappelle laugh and
you're like jogged around a little oh
really uh
yeah i don't want to brag about it but
yeah all right so it was after we got
fired i got fired okay i it was like a
couple months later i went to london
me and my friend went to london just to
have a week off like chilling okay and
chappelle was in town
someone from the cellar hooked it up for
me to oh cypher sounds oh he looked it
up for me to
go see the show and then chappelle knew
that i was there so he was like i want
to meet him
he wanted to meet me because he he's
interested in like the cantal culture
stuff
and we got to hang out and it was just
he like cleared everybody out it was
just me and my friend and dave mean
o'connor and dave chappelle just
drinking in london
and were you nervous there
no again it was all so surreal like it
was still so every single thing
that happened in like a four month span
you know
and uh i just told them a story about
louie
ck because that was another guy i was
became friends with kind of not friends
but like you know
yeah you just you're in people's circles
now so you meet these people but there i
was just telling chappelle a story about
because somebody was taking pictures of
me
talking to chappelle
and he was kind of like
let's not get some pictures with this
guy right now
i mean like this isn't the best he's
like i'm cool with cancer
yeah yeah yeah i don't we don't need
this i'm against cancer culture but i'm
not i don't want to be into pictures
like that picture like rumsfeld with
saddam hussein
we don't need this picture
and then uh
i told him a story about louie
coming into a it was at the patrice
o'neill benefit louie walked in
i was sitting with him and like a
photographer came over and i like leaned
to louie and i was like you want to get
a picture with me just like with
him i knew that's obviously a terrible
photo for both of us right it's like me
and louie together so you want to get a
picture together he was like no
i just remember him
and as soon as i told chappelle that he
was like no
he literally started running around
it was great it was a cool moment
was there ever a comedian you heard
laugh at your show that you were like oh
that's awesome louie really louie i saw
i was at the cellar i saw him laughing
and i was just like dude this is
that was my guy that's the guy that's my
favorite yeah man his special online is
so good he's so good it's so good yeah a
guy from here just went on the road and
opened up with him for a while i was
talking to him last night yeah chance
yeah that's awesome chance willie man
he's talented youngster
chappelle was another one that's like
that picture that we showed earlier that
was chappelle followed he went after me
oh cool and he got on it was like that
was funny and brought me back up
like that was really cool
that's cool man that was me doing the
louis story at the top
that's why i'm making the louis face oh
that's awesome oh yeah no one laughed at
that either
yeah you got to fight for comedy man we
have to fight to be able to joke around
isn't that crazy
yeah
yeah especially when most people know
you're joking that there's this is the
new government
yeah for sure
everyone knows you're joking even the
people writing the articles they know
it's a joke they have a bigger
agenda they're trying to push yeah and
they're pretending what you're saying is
serious yeah and that's just what it is
and that's fine right in fact it kind of
wouldn't be as funny if people weren't
getting upset right that's kind of you
know if we were all like nice pizza nice
swastika on that pizza dude right it'd
be like like if people thought that you
and i actually hated jewish people or
were fans of nazism
because we yes joked about or
if literally there would be zero
blowback for going on a podcast and
being like
here's some funny things about hitler
yeah it's not as dangerous it's not as
funny you know what i mean right that's
the point i'm trying to make right pizza
swastika
if those guys made that and sent that
and everybody at little caesars and the
people who received it were like
that was funny nice right it wouldn't be
as fun right right the backlash on that
one is that makes it funny people be
like what i can't believe this
i didn't know there were nazis at little
caesars yeah that's great it's making it
funnier you know that's interesting i
can't believe there's so many undercover
nazis at the comedy cellar yeah it's
like what
do you think there's nazis at the comedy
cellar
that's the crazy thing is that some
people think there really are it's like
i don't think there's one person that
voted for a republican yeah that's how
far away from fascism that is yeah yeah
yeah it's wild man it's a different time
dude
yeah i don't
i don't love talking about canceled
culture yeah kind of i guess sorry no no
no don't be sorry i'm kind of i mean i
did it i did it to myself i'm sorry
about that i'm kind of the culture guy
now so i don't know if you are it's also
just a fascinating topic right now i
know it's just it gets
like when people feel like it'll start
to just suddenly that's who you'll
always be then i don't think so i don't
think so either i'm confident i'm not
yeah i'm confident i'm good enough at
stand up that i'm not going to be
the guy you know that about yourself
then you can you're going to be fine
yeah i i'm i am fine i'm not i'm not
worried about that
uh i never really was i never was like
this is gonna it'll always be part of my
story that's how i was introduced into
the comedy world yeah but
was there any asian comedians that were
supportive
yeah
for sure that's cool for sure definitely
behind
right closed doors in fact everybody was
supportive behind the scenes right and
that's to my face too so i'm sure there
was a lot of them that weren't very
supportive that weren't just gonna walk
up to me like i've had problems with
people and i'm not going to walk up to
them be like you know you're a piece of
right so of course nobody's saying
it everything's kind of yeah uh but yeah
there were a lot of people for sure
that's cool man yeah i mean they i think
there were a lot of people that had
conversations with people that knew me
that actually knew me that were like oh
okay
you know like if you see a headline
you're like oh this guy said what
and then you look it up or you call his
friend and you're like is he like a
racist dude and they're like no not at
all he was around yeah it
changes things you're just like oh all
right yeah cause i read an article that
said he was racist well it's weird
because it makes it scary to talk about
anything sometimes because you're like
and it's also as podcasters it's like
they could go back through anything and
take out three or four words from so
many things for sure
absolutely
but
not many dudes are getting
i don't know snl seems like one of the
few jobs yeah that they would do that
for like they're not going to go back
and cancel guys
just willy-nilly they're not just gonna
like it's gotta be a big
you know if you're starring in a movie
then people might be like all right
let's take a look at him let's go listen
to a couple apps yeah see his episodes
well shane man uh thanks so much for
having me on the show last night and
yeah i'm a fan i feel like yeah same man
it's going to work nice to meet you bro
yeah
and uh
yeah wish you the best of luck and all
of that kind of jazz good man
hopefully you don't get in trouble from
this episode i'm probably we might do
you think we will or no no really see
that's what's interesting that's i'm so
excited i'll say this when i got in
trouble when we would get done with the
episode i'd be like we're gonna get in
trouble
like
i know what it is so is it weird then
that i feel that way sometimes it's
never it's never like
i've never gotten done with like an
episode where we said edgy things have
been like we're fine every time if i
think it's close i'm like
delete that huh that was bad we never
deleted but it's always like
this one no chance you're totally fine
we are you're fine i'm
i don't think i said anything that bad
sean what do you think we're good
riley mal you're an asian guy this is
the guy that did it to you how do you
feel
i feel great
if you remember what happened
i do
do you
i do oh nice
well not nice but i'm saying i'm
surprised you know about it because
sometimes when people don't know about
it
particularly when they're asian yeah i
got to be like
well here's what i said
like i'll get done with a show and there
will be asian there's obviously there's
asian people that like comedy right they
come to shows and they're like you were
our favorite tonight what's your name
mark norman
you know i mean you don't want to get
hit with the google in front of
you like they're like
what's your instagram i'll look it up
it's like shane gillis
that was that was the wildest part was
taking the train because i was poor when
i got canceled yeah so like that's the
only way i'd travel and like people
would be on the train like reading the
news and for three days i was the next
i was the news so people would literally
be like
like on the subway like looking at me
sitting there like did you try to look
nicer when you were the news do you
notice at all honestly definitely you
definitely act nicer to everyone around
you when you're in trouble like that oh
for sure you want everyone to think like
he's a nice guy yeah it's up but
you definitely become
a lot now maybe it's because you're not
as stressed about minor things where you
would have an ego with somebody about
like
you just bump me or some like
that right when you're getting canceled
you're like
i love you we love each other right like
it's like
you want everyone to like you because
you're getting
destroyed
publicly
maybe i wonder if that's why some
comedians always want everybody they
always
i wonder if there's some correlation in
there why a lot of comedians that's why
you want everybody to like you because
you feel like from the jump or something
you've you feel like a bad guy you feel
bad yes
maybe i think a lot of comedians feel
bad i feel bad yeah i feel bad most of
the time yeah
uh
but yeah when you when you're getting in
trouble
you're nice to everybody it's very funny
yeah that's cool yeah it's funny knowing
that like
harvey weinstein was probably nice as
hell towards the end
yeah the whole having to explain people
what happened is a tough one
yeah yeah
do you feel some type of way over there
riley mao
ah sometimes
no do you have any did you feel anything
about what shane did
oh um
no not really okay yeah i
you guys are good
i appreciate that i appreciate that of
course
i didn't mean anything i apologize
thanks theo that's a good one look at
this oh
how do you think that was going to go
here's the guy who did it there's that
son of a who did it how do you
feel about it
here's the opportunity i can't even see
him yeah well i can and it's not
comfortable
my bad man that was funny
oh jesus christ dude yeah bringing me
home be like we've actually brought
in one of your victims
it's like that like where you go
sit with the murderers
family or whatever oh um
shane gilles man thanks so much for
coming in bro thanks for your time dude
yeah this was great yeah this is great
thank you yeah you bet
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling like these leaves i
must be
cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
[Music]
but it's gonna take
a little time
for me to set that parking brake
and let myself on my heart
shine that light on me
i'll sit and tell you my story
[Music]
just
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my
hands
and these rails that i've been riding on
there
[Music]